Sabine Ezra Grand Admiral thrawn the
latest episode of Ahsoka revolves around
some of the franchise's most popular
characters and that's not necessarily a
good thing
a long time ago
in a galaxy far far away
ahsoka's sixth episode is arguably the
most exciting installment in the series
yet the adventure introduces a brand new
Galaxy a bewitching planet with a
mysterious backstory a few cutesy
creatures that will no doubt boost merch
sales and of course Grand Admiral thrawn
himself and that's not to mention the
long-awaited reunion between Sabine Wren
and Ezra Bridger however this episode
also typifies one of the biggest
problems with the Star Wars franchise in
recent years namely Ahsoka Tano is
relegated to the sidelines in episode 6.
she and who Yang receive a courtesy
scene at the beginning of the episode
but the rest of the story is dedicated
to sabine's Quest To Find Ezra there's
no denying that Sabine has always been
determined to find her friend but it's
been ahsoka's mission for a long time
too episode 6 robs her over goal and in
her own series no less this isn't the
first time that a Disney plus Star Wars
series has made the main character a
sidekick in their own show in fact this
is becoming something of a recurring
issue the book of Boba Fett rubbed Star
Wars fans the wrong way in a number of
ways the slow pacing frequent repetition
and poor character development are just
some of the criticisms that have been
lobbied at the Bounty Hunter's spin-off
series however arguably the biggest sin
was making him a side character and no
fewer than two episodes of his own solo
project chapter 5 and chapter 6 of The
Book of Boba Fett both see Boba take a
back seat to DIN jarin and grogu they're
pretty much the two best episodes in the
entire series too it's here that grogu
receives his Jedi training courtesy of
Luke Skywalker which is more significant
to the greater narrative than anything
that happens in boba's own Journey but
here's the thing Danny grogu already
have their own series giving them such a
prominent presence in the book of Boba
Fett took a lot of Shine off a character
who's been a fan favorite since The
Empire Strikes Back basically his first
solo outing will go down in history as a
missed opportunity to give him the focus
he deserve as well as the series fans
always wanted and again the characters
who overshadowed him were actually
subjected to the same treatment in their
own show
this is the way
the Mandalorian started out as a story
about a Wandering Bounty Hunter dinjaran
eventually takes on the role of
protector to the adorable grogu and the
relationship quickly becomes the focus
of the show unfortunately in season 3
the main players get lost in the shuffle
as other characters take precedence the
book of Boba Fett's is partly to blame
for this the titular Bounty Hunter
series reunites Dan and his little green
sidekick after they were separated in
the mandalorian's second season and the
resolution robs her own series of an
engaging storyline with stakes and drama
the end result okatan crease of all
people turns out to be the main
character in The Mandalorian season 3.
the show's meatiest storyline Chronicles
her journey to reunite the people of
Mandalore which is an interesting art
for her but not for the characters the
show is supposed to be about meanwhile
dyn's quest for Redemption among his
people is resolved in just a few
episodes undermining his entire Journey
until that point it's clumsy
storytelling and it's understandable why
there are concerns about Ahsoka
experiencing similar issues it remains
to be seen how the rest of ahsoka's
first season will play out but the
current sign suggests the danger of her
becoming the latest victim some of the
franchise's sidekick Trend sabine's
Journey has arguably been the most
interesting so far in episode 6
positions her as a potential star of the
show moving forward additionally with a
fan favorite character like Ezra back on
the board the upcoming episodes will
undoubtedly be dedicated to continuing
his story as well but will that also
come at the cost of Ahsoka being given
less to do episode 6 does tease a future
showdown between Ahsoka and thrawn
though it's likely that Ezra will also
factor into the final battle with a
grand Admiral at this point it's
probably fair to say that most of the
Disney Plus shows exist to contribute to
a larger overarching story with many
moving parts that's fine of course but
many fans will no doubt hope that
they're able to make these protagonists
feel more integral to their own
Adventures
foreign